(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] This small
three-acre island is home to one
of the most cherished sea temples in Bali.
(upbeat music)
Tanah Lot translates to Land in the Sea
in the Balinese language,
which perfectly describes
this rock formation
and the temple that sits atop it.
It can be found along the
southwest coast of Bali
and is one of seven ocean
temples each of which
was built within eye line of the next.
Tanah Lot was built
around the 16th century
to honor the sea spirits.
It is believed that it is
protected by sea serpents.
The rock base that the temple
sits on has been reconstructed
over time as the original
rock had begun crumbling
into the ocean.
Visitors are able to
access the island via foot
during low tide.
However, non Balinese
people are not permitted
to enter the temple.
This is one of the most visited
and photographed temples
in Bali, and it is especially
busy at sunrise and sunset.
Although, if you intend to
visit, don't bring a date.
It is believed there is a
curse on unmarried couples
who visit the temple.
Their relationship is doomed.
(upbeat music)
But this view might
just be worth the risk.